wall street gets stunked as reddit games
the game stops stock
san francisco decides to crack down on
schools named after abraham lincoln and
george washington
and john kerry is reporting for climate
ruler
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in one
moment first gotta remind you i just
said it you need to get expressvpn why
well big tech is not going to protect
you okay the reality is that your
information is being used by bigtech
in order to monetize their platforms
they're then using those platforms to
shut down perspectives that you like
and to censor people that you want to
hear from so why exactly should you
contribute
your information to them so they can
make money off of you
well you can prevent all of that just by
using express vpn
did you believe a vpn isn't for you
because you can use the internet just
fine without one
well anytime you go online your isp can
see every site you're visiting
are you confused about how it works
expressvpn is an app for computers and
smartphones it encrypts your network
data
and reroutes it through a secure server
that means you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked
do you think vpns are complex only for
tech experts take it from me they are
not with expressvpn you launch the app
and tap just one button to protect
yourself it really is
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they're
rated number one by cnet and wired they
stand for my values as well take back
your privacy
at expressvpn.com get three extra months
for free
on a one-year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben's get three extra months for free
visit expressvpn.com
ben right now alrighty so the big news
of the day is that essentially a bunch
of memesters just took down half of wall
street
okay so a couple things just to start
off one it can be hilarious and also
not good for society right these two
things can be true at once it is
hilarious when you're high school
fellows
tp your high school gym teacher's house
like that's really really funny
okay also not a wonderful thing to do it
doesn't provide a lot of social value
so a lot of people today i'm seeing are
cheering this oh look they're taking
down the hedge fund bros those hedge
funds those hedge fund pros deserve it
because of what they've been doing with
their short selling okay so
let me first explain what the what is
happening i'm going to give you the
story
then i'm going to explain exactly how
all of this works and i'm also going to
explain what a stock market is for
because i think there is a fundamental
disconnect between what people think the
stock market is there to do
and therefore what people do when they
trade in the stock market
and what the stock market actually
accomplishes and why it provides its
social good
the underlying theme that a lot of
people seem to be carrying forth today
is that people who trade in the stock
market people
who are day traders hedge fund guys the
investment bankers
right all those guys are bad people they
are bad people because they're quote
unquote speculators they're not adding
value
to the system this seems to be the the
idea that undergirds
all of the animus that is leading people
to cheer wildly for what all of these
reddit folks are now doing with regard
to the gamestop stock but
here's what you need to keep in mind
when it comes to the stock market
just like any other market people who
work in a market do so to make money
but because free markets also provides
social value in that transactions
generally provide a value to both sides
and also provide other information to
the more general society
okay that is what folks in the stock
market are doing every time
you go to the supermarket and you buy an
apple a couple of things are happening
one you're getting an apple two the
grocery store is getting the price
of the apple and three you are impacting
the overall price
of the price of apples generally right
so if a lot of people rush
to the apple store to the to the
supermarket they'll buy apples at the
same time
the price of apples is going to
skyrocket why because
you are now conveying that there's an
extraordinarily high demand for the
apples and there is not enough supply
for the apples
okay and that is a social good because
that allows for proper reallocation of
distribution it means that now everybody
knows we need to grow more apples now
everybody knows we need to ship more
apples to the grocery store
pricing mechanisms are not merely just a
thing that happens
pricing mechanisms allow for proper
reallocation of resources this is true
in every business ever it's true at the
grocery store it is true at the
bookstore it is true at the furniture
store it is true everywhere
and it is true when it comes to the
stock market as well so here's what the
stock market exists to do just like the
grocery store
it exists to allow you to buy a stock
and then own stock in a particular
company
and exists to allow companies to sell
their stock so as to raise money for the
things they want to do
right so it provides them liquidity
events they can sell their stock you get
to own the stock which is great
they get to sell their stock and they
get to take your money and then invest
it
in growth of the company or if they are
badly run in bonuses for the executives
that are undeserved right they get but
they get to decide that
and then if you don't like how they are
handling that money well then how do you
reprice that
well the way that people reprice that
when a company is badly run is by doing
something
called short selling because again
there's a third aspect to the market
just like the grocery store there's a
third aspect to the stock market and
that is
all of the interactions in the stock
market are supposed to provide
information to the general public
about whether a company is being well
run or poorly run
about what the proper pricing of the
company is about what the company is
worth about what others should be paying
for the stock
of the particular company so it is not
like a roulette wheel it is not like a
casino people tend to think of the stock
market like a casino
because they buy a stock and then it
goes up or they buy a stock and then it
goes down
okay but that does not convey the fact
that there are a bunch
of actual things that are happening in
the stock market that are quite good for
society
one again is the ability of companies to
sell their stocks so they can then use
that money to invest in their workers
and if you work for a publicly traded
company the reason that they have the
money to do that is because
originally somebody ipo'd and then took
that money and
and poured it into the company okay so
that is purpose number one purpose
number two is that people like you
can own a 401k so they can own stock in
companies that they have no
business running you don't run coca-cola
but you can own stock in coca-cola
right you don't own any of these
publicly you don't own apple but you can
own stock
in apple and you can become an owner of
apple that's a really cool thing okay
and then third
the stock market exists through all of
these transactions
it exists in order to provide a proper
pricing mechanism because if you just
tabularaza said okay what
how much is it gonna cost me for one
share of the you know 100 million shares
of apple stock that are out there
how much is it gonna cost me for that
you have no idea really you have no idea
in the same way that you really have no
idea if you walked into a store right
now with no other information about
planet earth
and somebody offered you an apple you
would have no idea what the apple cost
the way that you know what the apple
cost and the way that the grocery store
knows what the apple costs is because
they are competing with other
competitors in the market to sell you
apples
and because all of those competitors are
attempting to balance out how much it
costs to bring that apple to market and
more importantly what the demand level
for the apples is okay the same thing is
true of stock if you say i want to i
want a share of apple stock with no
other information
you have no idea what that could be
worth i don't have any idea what that
can be worth there are people who spend
every day all day simply analyzing
what apple is doing internally what the
demand for apple stock is like what the
surrounding market conditions are like
and therefore you are able to with a
certain level of certitude
buy an apple stock knowing that it is
not wildly mispriced now
what the best traders will do is they
will look for mispricings in the market
and then they will exploit those
pricings in the market
to bring themselves money right if they
if they see that a stock is wildly
overpriced
then what they will do is they will
short sell and now
that seems like predatory right oh my
god they're short selling a stock that's
terrible they're short selling a stock
okay what they are doing is they're
they're looking to make money they're
not altruists
but what that ends up doing is conveying
to the market that the stock price
is too high right when you have a bunch
of people who are short selling a stock
that conveys to the market that the
stock is overpriced and that too many
people are invested in the stock
and so the stock price starts to re
reprice it starts to revalue to the
point where it's an
accurate assessment of the value right
in the same way where if you said okay
listen i think
that six months from now there is going
to be
a glut of apples on the market so what
i'm going to do today
is i'm going to buy the right to
essentially
buy apples today and i'm i'm going to
let me explain short selling okay in
order to do this i sort of have to
explain short selling because this is
what we are talking about today in terms
of gamestop
so here's what short selling is this is
again a way of of
using a price mechanism in order to
figure out what the true value of stocks
is
so here's what a short sell is if you
want to make money off
your assessment that a company is
overvalued you can participate in what
is called a short sale
what a short sale is is you borrow a
share from somebody else
and then you sell it on the market today
and you promise the person that you
borrowed
that you're going to give them back the
stock in a month with a little bit of
interest
okay so let's say that i think that the
gamestop stock is overvalued today
and i know that producer mathis has a
share of game stop
stock so i go to mathis and i say listen
mathis
i'm going to give you 10 bucks in order
so that you can give me
your gamestop stock right i want you to
give it to me in a month i'm gonna
return you
that gamestop stock with the ten dollars
right so you for for essentially just
lending me your stock
i'm going to give you back ten dollars
in addition to your stock
so mathis goes okay perfect sounds great
mathis is the brokerage in this
particular example
i then take that game stop stock i look
at the price of the stock it's now 200
i sell it at 200 now i have 200 in my
pocket and my assumption is that in a
month
the game stop stock is not going to be
200 it is going to be
50 right and so now i take
the i sell the stock at 200 in a month i
go back into the market i buy a stock
and then i take that stock and i return
it to mathes right i spend 50 bucks on
the stock a month from now i'd sold it
at 200
a month ago now i'd spend 50 bucks on
the stock i take it i give it back to
mathis i pocket the difference
right i make 150 bucks on the pure
market transaction
140 bucks after i pay math this is 10
bucks back mathis gets back his stock
now is that me being predatory or is
that me looking at the market and
realizing that this
stock is overpriced and not only that
isn't it conveying to the market
something that is true which is that the
stock
is overpriced right that the stock does
cost too much money that the company is
not run
as well as some people are saying that
the company is run okay so that is what
a
a short sale is okay so what happened
here
is that there are a bunch of people in
the hedge fund industry who looked at
the
company gamestop and they said this
company's overvalued
we're short selling the stock we think
that right now the stock for gamestop
is just excessively expensive and so we
are going to short sell right we're
going to borrow a bunch of shares today
we are going to sell them on the open
market and then a month from now
we are going to buy back the gamestop
stock and then we are going to return it
back to the brokerages
so what is now happening is that a bunch
of people don't like the hedge fund
managers right they don't like
they think the hedge funds for both
maybe a couple good reasons and mostly
bad reasons there are a couple reasons
why people don't like the hedge fund
managers
one is there's a broad overall feeling
that motivated both the tea party and
occupy wall street back in the early
2010s
that feeling is these guys bear no real
risk that if things go bad
somebody will step in to protect them
that if things go bad if they
make a bet and the bet goes wrong the
federal government is going to step in
and pay them off
and you don't get that and i don't get
that but they get it now i think that
that is a justified rage
i think that is true okay there's
something else that is happening too
people are looking at the current
economy and they're looking at the stock
market and they're saying i don't
understand why a bunch of people are
making money off the stock market
even though the economy is in the
doldrums and right now they're
billion a bajillion people out of work
but these hedge fund guys are just
making a fortune
in the stock market why are they allowed
to do that so some of this is just
pure jealousy some of this is why are
these guys so disconnected from the real
economy
and the answer is they are not
disconnected from the real economy
and if they were to bear their risk
which is what they should do if they
were to bear their risk
then they are bearing the risk that the
economy will downturn but the reason the
stock market has remained high
throughout this entire pandemic is
because of the correct assumption
that these stock traders are making
which is that eventually we are going to
come
out of the pandemic and the stocks are
going to be worth a lot more than they
are today because we have pumped money
into the system because people are going
to go back to work
because this is an artificial recession
because what we are watching right now
thanks to the lockdowns and thanks to
the pandemic
is a an easily foreseeable artificial
recession and so they are pricing the
future into the present value of stocks
okay so if you're just angry at the
hedge fund guys because they're doing
a job that actually provides some social
value but also makes them rich
then i don't have a lot of sympathy for
you if you're angry at the hedge fund
guys because you believe they don't bear
any downside risk and the
government's going to bail them out the
truth is you shouldn't be angry at them
as much as you should be angry at the
government for bailing them out
the government shouldn't be bailing
anybody out the government should not be
bailing people out when they make a bad
stock pick
and that's true of hedge fund guys it's
true lehman brothers it's true of
everybody you make a
bad investment in subprime mortgages you
should bear the risk of that
okay so in a second i'm gonna explain
what the gamestop
reddit guys did because again it is both
hilarious
and also it cuts directly against the
social value of the stock market
because remember the stock market is
there for three things to provide
liquidity for companies to allow you to
invest and three to properly price
stocks right that is what it is there to
do and explain what happened
with gamestop and why it undercuts a lot
of the fundamental purposes of the
market even if it happens to be
really really really funny okay so i'm
gonna get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that if you
need a good night's sleep if you are
looking for a good night's sleep you
need a great pillow i know you don't
think about those pillows
you got under your head but they're
messing with your neck they're not
making you feel great when you wake up
every morning they go flat over time
what you need is my pillow my pillow
products do not go flat you can wash and
dry them as many times as you want they
maintain
their shape and they're made in the
united states if you don't have a my
pillow
or you know somebody who doesn't now
would be the time to get one because for
a limited time my pillow is offering
premium my pillows for their lowest
price ever you can get a queen size
premium my pillow regularly 69.98
for just 29.98 today that is 40 bucks in
savings kings are only five dollars more
folks now would be the time to buy not
only are you getting the lowest price
ever but they're the best gifts ever
2998 for a queen size premium my pillow
by now they'll extend the 60 day money
back guarantee to march 1
20 21 head on over to mypillow.com click
on the radio listeners square
there you will find not only that
amazing offer but also deep discounts on
their other products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper and my pillow
telesets call
800 651 1148 or and use promo code daily
wear when you do
800 651 1148 use promo code
daily wire when you call that number for
the special my pillow deals okay so
here is what the gamestop reddit guys
are doing the meme makers
okay and it again hilarious also not
great for the market
and not great for people who invest in
the markets typically so what's
happening right now
is there a bunch of guys who are not big
institutional investors
although we'll see some institutional
investors have jumped in on the action
and what they are doing is they're doing
what is called a short squeeze okay so
go back to our short sale
example i borrow money uh i borrow a
stock from mathis i borrow a gamestop
stock from mathis with a promise that in
a month i'm going to repay him 10
plus the stock i then go out and i sell
it at 200 a month from now
i sell it a month from now i buy it
another stock
from gamestop for 50 bucks i pocket the
difference everybody with me okay
so imagine that the reverse happens
imagine that i make a i make a bad
decision and i actually am wrong the
value of gamestop
is higher than i thought it was going to
be so i borrow a stock from mathis
with the promise to repay him his stock
plus 10 bucks
and then i sell it at 200 bucks but a
month from now
the price is not 50 the price is 300 so
what do i do
i owe mathis to stock i owe him his 10
but the price went up not down
so now i have to come out of pocket
right now i have to actually go and buy
the stock at 300
and i've lost 100 on the transaction and
after i pay math this is brokerage fee
i've lost 110
on the transaction because i sold the
stock for 200 now i have to buy back a
stock at 300
and pay mathis back 10 so i've lost 110
bucks on this particular transaction
okay so this is what is called a short
squeeze okay sometimes it happens sort
of naturally
a short squeeze can also happen when
people just decide they are going to
jack
the short sellers now the way that you
do this is you artificially boost the
price of the stock
right you get the price of the stock up
to 300 even though the stock really
should be down to 50.
and that is what is happening right now
okay so
as gamestop stock was rising
precipitously
short sellers were forced to hedge their
bets and then
they have to buy the stock in order to
make up for their losses right they now
have to buy the stock and
they have to buy more options so you get
a bubble right they have to buy
because they know eventually this bubble
is going to burst so here's what
happened
all of these guys on reddit decided
we're going to just f
with the game with the game stock this
game stop
short sellers we're gonna f with the
hedge funds and what we're gonna do is
we are all going to buy
gamestop stock all at once and this led
to some
actual kind of stock market hilarity in
the sense that gamestop is not a
particularly profitable corporation
gamestop became one of the most
expensive corporations
on planet earth like it was worth more
than tesla okay
that's absurd it's absurd on its face
according to the wall street journal
here's how they report this the power
dynamics are shifting on wall street
individual investors are winning big at
least for now and relishing it
an eye-popping rally and shares of
companies that were once left for dead
including gamestop amc entertainment and
blackberry ltd
has upended the natural order between
hedge funds investors and those trying
their hand at trading from their sofas
while individuals are rejoicing at
newfound riches the pros are reeling
from their losses and so people are
saying this is like a david versus
goliath sort of thing although it's
a little simplistic as we'll explain in
a moment long held strategies such as
evaluating company fundamentals have
gone out the window in favor of
momentum right this is what i was saying
about this undermines the actual
function of the market which is to
properly value companies if you just
have a bunch of people who decide today
they're gonna buy stock in blockbuster
which is exactly what's happening
my blockbuster stock is worth buckets
because blockbuster has not been a thing
for
quite a while right they're not a
competitive company and so if you decide
that you're going to randomly drive up
the price of the stock
then you're not actually doing anybody a
favor except yourself
in fact in certain circumstances this is
illegal
right if you engage in what is what is
called a pump and dump
that that's clearly legality so think
back to the movie wall street if you
ever saw the movie wall street with um
with um michael douglas there's a scene
where bud fox who's played by charlie
sheen you'll remember this he is calling
everybody on earth that he knows
and he's saying and he's saying uh
blue what is it it's a blue horse who
loves anacot steel
he's saying blue horse who loves anacott
steel what he means by that is that
institutional investors they love anacot
steel they think anacot's steel is
really undervalued you should all buy
okay so he pumps up the price of the
stock and he gets in early
so if you go to some and so let's say
that now i want to pump up anacot steel
right so i buy a share in anacott steel
then i go to all my friends and i say
guys
let me tell you anacot steel is a
bargain okay right now it is super duper
undervalued you need to buy it right now
i know that it's not undervalued
i know that actually is properly valued
but instead i lie i say it's really
really undervalued and so i artificially
drive up the price of the stock because
now everybody wants
anacot steel and then i say oh well you
know what time to sell
right and i sell so i bought anacot
steel at a buck i drove up the price
all the way to 100 bucks and i sold it
100 bucks okay now
what can happen right there is you can
end up with these bubbles where last one
out is the rotten egg
right because all of my friends if they
were one of the first investors and they
got it at five and now it's up to 100
you don't want to be the one who's left
holding the bag okay now if you false
falsely advertise this if you say
anacott steel is under value that's why
you should buy it
that's illegal right that's illegal pump
and dump if however
you don't do that and this is what the
reddit guys were doing they weren't
saying gamestop
was undervalued when they did this when
they when they artificially drove
up the price of the stock they didn't
say gamestop is undervalued
they said we know that it is properly
valued we just want to screw with the
hedge fund guys
so that's not illegal right it's just a
it's just a prank
it's it's a very damaging prank for
those hedge fund guys because now
they're caught in that short squeeze i
was talking about where they have to pay
back stock
that they don't own so they have to go
into the market they have to buy the
stock the need to buy the stock
continues to drive the price up and
they're now buying stock options
right they're now buying options to sell
later
or to or to buy later on they're they're
buying they are they're short selling
they're continuing to short sell and buy
into the market at the same time because
they know that eventually the stock
price is going to drop again
they say now they're short selling so
the problem is
that the longer you do this the longer
it is the more the bubble builds up
right so the question is can you hold
the line so a lot of the early investors
on reddit
got out already a lot of the guys on
reddit who who bought the game
stop stock they took the ride they sold
but somebody's gonna get left holding
the bag
the people who typically are not gonna
get left holding the bag are the
institutional investors
right it's gonna be the more
unsophisticated players who were buying
into the hold the line
we're gonna screw the hedge fund guys
the hedge fund guys are gonna be okay
they're all gonna go get revolving lines
of credit
they're going to buy the stock that they
need they're going to take a loss
on this particular transaction and
they'll be okay it's the people who are
going to buy into game stock when it is
at 300
and is actually valued at 25 and don't
get out in time because they were told
by all their friends hey look we're
jacking the hedge fund guys we're going
to lose money
okay so this is again this is what
happens when you undermine
the value proposition of the stock
market by completely ignoring what the
stock market is supposed to do which is
properly valued companies
and all of it is based on pure animus
for the hedge fund guys some of it
justified as i explained
a lot of it unjustified and simple
jealousy of the fact that they're people
who make money in the stock market and
maybe you are not one of them
and so we'll get to more of this in just
one second
first we need to talk about the fact
that you
need you need to give your business the
messaging tools to turn your website
into a thriving storefront
okay how do you do this well you need to
use text messaging so too many companies
are not actually using text messaging in
order to make their companies grow
right for for getting back to clients
and coordinating meetings and
and reaching out to customers instead
they're using sort of old-fashioned
techniques for going after folks and it
just doesn't work instead
what they need is podium you can connect
with leads customers and teammates as
easily as text messaging when you close
the deal podium
even makes it easy to get paid contact
free via text
podium is the ultimate messaging
platform for local businesses with
podium reviews you can easily text
customers to leave an online review
improving search rankings podium web
chat lets website visitors text with
your team right from your home page
you can meet with customers from
anywhere with podium video chat get paid
fast with text
over podium payments podium inbox podium
inbox brings it all together you can
keep the leads warm you can respond to
feedback all in
one place it makes business way way
easier and way
more profitable rpm alamo increased
business by 20 the bridal collection
processed over 200 000
in no contact payments find out how
podium can help your business reach more
customers get started free today
at podium.com great way to grow your
business that is podium.com
shapiro if you're not using text in
order to reach your customers you're
doing it wrong
go check out podium.com shapiro and make
your business
more efficient okay so the wall street
journal says long-held strategies such
as evaluating company fundamentals have
gone out the window in favor of momentum
war has broken out between professional
professionals losing billions
and individual investors cheering at
them on social media
meanwhile the frenzy of activity is
stirring regulatory and legal concerns
as well as the attention of the biden
administration newbie investors are
gathering on platforms like reddit
discord facebook and twitter they're
encouraging each other to pile into
stocks bragging about their gains and at
times
intentionally banding together to
intensify losses among professional
traders who protest that social media
hordes are conspiring to move stock
prices
i didn't realize it was this cult like i
said short seller andrew left of citroen
research who's become a particular
target
of some investors on social media it's
just a get-rich-quick scheme gamestop
amc blackberry have received hundreds of
thousands of mentions across social
media since early january
have vaulted into the ranks of the most
traded stocks in the us market
the mammoth gains have forced money
managers to dump bets that the stocks
would fall
magnifying the rally right so that means
that they have to buy the stock in order
to pay
pay back the uh the short selling they
were doing bearish investors who took
short positions have lost
23.6 billion dollars this year through
the close of trading wednesday and
gamestop alone
according to s3 partners including 14.3
billion dollars on wednesday when the
stock price jumped 135
that was the largest percentage increase
in history to a record of 347.51
on wednesday gamestop shares hit a high
of 380
380 bucks briefly giving the video game
retailer a market value of 26.5 billion
more than that of delta so
all of this is is absurd right on its
face it's absurd
the the question is whether this is you
know the people who are
striking back at the bad guys or whether
they're actually just sort of gaming the
market
for fun and giggles and to make a little
bit of extra money so the line that i've
seen is they're just doing what the
hedge fund guys are doing
well first of all if the hedge fund guys
banded together to pump it up a stock
kind of illegal so not quite the same
now the hedge fund guys got together and
they're like
you know what we're just going to tell
all our investors that the stock isn't
worth
what we think what we're about to do
we're just going to make a gamble that
we can create a momentum play i'm going
to be perfectly obvious about that
that's not illegal everybody is caveat
m2 or buyer beware
okay but the the sort of enthusiasm that
we're seeing for this
i think a lot of this is just a certain
class based enthusiasm which is the
hedge fund guys are jerks and
i know a lot of hedge fund guys some
guys are real jerks some guys are not
just like every other industry
okay but again there is a lot of
enthusiasm for what's going on right now
because it's sort of like the little guy
is screwing the big guy
well some of those guys are little guys
some of those guys are in fact not
little guys and this is worth pointing
out
and the reality is that according to
bloomberg
there are a bunch of institutional
investors who are making bank
off this sort of thing right it is not
just little guys who are making money
off of this
right wang xianlin is up 773 million
dollars that guy's an institutional
investor as amc entertainment spikes
soaring shares have added 185 million
dollars of worth to the ceo of tootsie
rolls fortune because people have been
buying up the stock of tootsie roll okay
so it is not merely
the the little guy who's making a bunch
of money and by the way it's gonna be
the little guy who gets screwed
yes they're a bunch of hedge fund
billionaires who are gonna get screwed
and
okay right they took a risk and then
they got jacked by a bunch of people who
are basically pranking them for money
but that's you know risk
risk reward calculations don't always go
right it's not illegal what these what
these folks are doing
and it can be kind of funny with that
said the people who are going to get
left holding the bag in the main are
going to be
unsophisticated non-institutional
investors who end up holding the stock
too long and then
ending up eating the loss is basically
what's going to end up happening here
right wang the founder of closely held
conglomerate a daily and wanda group
now owns a stake with about 1 billion
dollars in amc which climbs almost 20
bucks in europe trading
the most since october of 2018. and so
there are a lot of people who are
big players who are making a lot of
money off of this okay but again the the
underlying
idea here is that the stock market is
kind of bad or that hedge fund guys are
doing something deeply moral when they
short sell
i don't buy either of those things i
think there are people who do immoral
things in every market
i think that is true in virtually every
market but it is worth noting hedge fund
guys
are generally competing against one
another if they think that somebody is
undervaluing a stock
then they will go after those people
these folks are sharks the hedge fund
guys are sharks
okay so here's a cnbc guest shamit
palahapiyata
i'm screwing up his name chamath
palihapi tia
he's the social capital ceo and he's
going off on
cnbc saying that you know anybody who's
upset about this
in the wall street world is basically
just crapping on the little guy
well no i think that what the little guy
is doing here is perfectly legal i don't
think that it is particularly good for
the broader social implications of the
market
right it just reinforces the idea that
the market is a casino which the market
is not and should not be but here he is
defending the
what is going on with gamestop right now
i'm not saying they shouldn't be able to
use something you want to say you're
saying they should participate on your
terms
no on wall street's terms no in a way
where they get to when when wall street
can have the best of it they can maybe
participate on the side
but then when wall street gets the worst
of it they their parents
their relatives will just come and bail
him out so if you want to fix it
i think you got to go and ask for the
same transparency because you can't all
of a sudden
have your cake and eat it too let's have
hedge funds operate in the shadows but
let's then basically land bask wall
street vets because they actually have
the courage to write their stuff down
publicly where anybody can see it okay
so his call is for the hedge fund guys
to be transparent about why they are
investing the way they're investing and
honestly i don't think that's a bad idea
i think that's totally fine
um but i will note that typically the
market is not i mean this is a perfect
example of a stock just being wildly
overpriced
and they're now doing it stock by stock
they're just going to every every stock
that is being short sold because these
stocks are overvalued because the
companies are not doing well
and they're now pumping those up and
then dumping them i mean that's that's
essentially
what they are doing okay so the response
is also bad because everything is bad so
the response
has been to ban the reddit wall street
bets server
for at least a little while discord
banned the reddit wall street bet server
the company confirmed to the verge
reddit's wall street bets subreddit is
the driver of an unprecedented rally of
gamestop stock and has received a great
deal of attention in the press
as the stock continues to soar now
discord says it didn't ban the server
for financial fraud
instead it was banned because it
continued to allow quote hateful and
discriminatory content
after repeated warnings yeah that's bull
crap that is not true
okay so it is what happened here is that
all these companies these hedge funds
and the government probably went to
discord and said these people are
manipulating stock prices i want you to
take it down
even though it's not technically illegal
okay so this actually looks a lot more
like what the government and what the
media and what institutional players
have been doing with social media right
where they say we don't like a
particular point of view we know that
it's not illegal but we want you to take
it down
it's sort of like what all of these
major institutional government players
said to amazon web services to have them
take down parlor that's what this sort
of looks like
right is we don't like the wall street
bets subreddit
so take it down because it's doing us
damage and then pretend that it's on the
basis of hateful content that's nonsense
it's not true okay because how about the
timing
was there not hateful content a week ago
or two weeks ago i'm sure there was
and so the timing is that people got
upset and then they're like okay we're
gonna ban this thing
now that is a real violation of rights
okay i don't have to love
what the wall street bets guys are doing
right now again i don't i think that
they are undercutting one of the
fundamental tenets of the market which
is that you are attempting to properly
price stock
with that said i think taking down the
ability of people to talk about stock in
ways that you don't like
is deeply violative of basic first
amendment
concepts that's a private company again
it can do it
but a first amendment culture does not
go along with this sort of thing and it
just demonstrates where the institutions
of power truly lie
which is not with the people and it's
not with individuals and that merely
reinforces the feeling that the hedge
fund guys have disproportionate
influence
over what is happening in our financial
world it's a really really bad move to
take down
the the subreddit that should not be a
thing that happens
it really shouldn't now that said if
you're cheering this on mainly because
you don't like hedge fund guys and
because they have slicked back hair and
because they're rich and drive fancy
cars
um let me suggest you that you actually
have to find the bad thing that they
have done in order to dislike them
otherwise it's just pure jealousy
if they're taking bailouts that is a
reason to dislike them
if they are actively engaging in
misinformation campaigns directed at
companies
that is a reason to dislike them if they
are gaming the market that's a reason to
dislike them if they're just engaging in
short selling because they believe that
a company is overvalued
and if their competitors are doing the
same
that's not doing something wrong i don't
think that the reddit guys are i think
the reddit guys the only thing they're
doing wrong here
uh is that i think that the the
motivations here are pretty much revenge
and an open acknowledgement that they
are not really interested in providing
any service to the market other than
a sort of pump and dump me and my
friends are going to get rich and the
and the wall street bros are going to
pay again can be hilarious just like
your high school teacher getting tp'd
but that does not mean that it is
providing a giant social service or that
we should all be
cheering on this sort of thing as a
matter of routine because the stock
market is bad like really what's the
alternative the alternative is that we
have people who are wildly overvaluing
stock
who are simply playing the pump and dump
game and then
why would anybody trade in the stock
market right then it's a private people
of liquidity it deprives people of
solidity in their 401ks
there are real consequences to treating
the stock market like a casino the dirty
secret of the stock market is that it's
not a casino
okay and that most people who are
engaged in the stock market including
institutional investors
are not playing it like a casino i know
that the popular view of the stock
market once again
is that it is a casino and that they're
winners and there are losers it's just
people betting
that is not what it is it's a market
it's called the market just like your
grocery store
just like your bookstore just like any
other market and just because people get
disproportionately rich off of that does
not mean
that they're not providing an ancillary
social value they are in fact this does
not provide ancillary social value what
is happening right now
it doesn't it provides hilarity so if
hilarity is an ancillary social value
it is really funny you have people who
are now controlling the stock market who
are posting memes
of aragorn telling people to hold the
line like that
like that's kind of funny they basically
have a bunch of jokesters who are now
controlling
wide swaths of the economy it's funny
until it's not funny it's funny until it
comes time for you to invest your
your actual salary in the stock market
you look around and go
can i even buy into apple knowing that
these people could jack the stock
tomorrow
like just just as a just for the bleeps
and giggles of it
probably it's not good precedent so all
the people who are cheering today again
if you want to direct your ire against
the government please do it
i'm with you none of the people on wall
street should currently be bailed out
even though they're getting jacked right
now they should not be bailed out
the government should not be intervening
right now the government should never
have intervened
with regard to bailing out the stock
market
but that's ira that should be directed
at the government which is answerable to
you
the sort of punishment of private
industry for engaging
in what it is they do is i think a bad
precedent and i know there's an
unpopular view
but again if you believe that a stock
market should exist and then it provides
social value
then you have to explain why what's
going on today is providing consummate
social value
okay now in a second we're going to get
to the continuation of the destruction
of public education in the united states
first let us talk about the fact that if
you got a medical issue and you got to
get dissolved
why would you wait around on it with
roman you get a free online evaluation
and ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home a healthcare professional will work
with you to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate
roman then ships it to you with free
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward
simple and discreet getting started is
simple just go to getroman.com
complete an online visit erectile
dysfunction used to be tough to tackle
now there is roman
complete an online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and take care of it
go to getroman.com ben today
if you are approved you get 15 off that
first order of ed treatment again that's
getroman.com
ben getroman.com slash fan a lot of
folks if they have an embarrassing
medical issue they sort of wait on it
hope that it goes away why would you
waste your life waiting on a medical
problem that you could get solved
today quickly easily discreetly and
inexpensively go to getroman.com
ben today again getroman.com and if you
are approved you get 15 bucks off your
first order of ed treatment
getroman.com ben okay in just a second
we'll get to the continuation
of the undermining of american education
and also to joe biden
and company who are um are now sounding
off
on the gamestop situation and their
response is just as stupid and hilarious
as you would expect it would be we'll
get to that in a moment first
daily wire we are fighting in the
culture what that means is that we are
getting involved in the entertainment
industry we released our first film run
hide fight exclusively for daily wire
members you can catch it over at
dailywire.com
on our mobile app on our streaming apps
at apple tv and roku if you're not a
daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that is our hf run hide fight for 25
percent off
you'll notice that there's a vast gap on
rotten tomatoes between the critics who
said that the
the subject matter was distasteful and
our audiences who loved it
that's the kind of stuff we're probably
gonna make we're gonna make stuff that
the woke don't love
but you do you can catch it over on
dailywire.com on our mobile app on our
streaming apps at apple tv and roku if
you're not a daily ware member yet use
promo code rhf run hide fight to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 off you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative radio show and podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so quick note now final sort of
referendum on the
gamestop thing so today on on twitter
eat the rich is trending it's pretty
obvious what exactly a lot of this
gamestop stuff is about and the sort of
populace on both sides sharing it
because they don't like the stock market
generally uh that's that's a
it's a weird take and i'm wondering
exactly how you are adding social value
again this is um it's very it's very
foolish and again the solution is not
going to be the government
naturally the biden administration has
the best possible response
so jen sackey the brand new and not very
good white house press secretary for the
biden administration was asked about
gamestop her response was one of the
dumbest responses i've ever heard to a
thing
here she was she was asked to remember
the question was what do you guys think
about the gamestop thing
and what are you going to do about the
fact that people are artificially
boosting the prices
of particular stocks in order to pump
and dump them effectively what are you
gonna do about that
uh and here is jen sackey's answer is
the way i was concerned about the stock
market activity we're seeing around game
stop
um and now with some other stocks as
well uh including
the something here or whatever the
company that was
uh blockbuster um and have there been
any conversations with the
sec about how to proceed
well um i'm also happy to repeat that we
have the first female treasury secretary
and a team that's surrounding
her and often questions about market
we'll send to them
oh well i mean now that we know that the
treasury secretary uh has a vagina
i guess that that solves all the
problems well done there remember the
question was
what do you do about the game stop thing
and she's like well our treasury
secretary is a biologically woman
well i guess problem solved then gang
geniuses
in charge always the this is why the
government actually should not get
involved
let it play out let it play out people
are gonna learn their lesson when they
hold on to the stock too long and the
only people who got rich were the reddit
people who were manipulating the market
at the very beginning
right when the blue horse shot uh blue
horseshoe buying anticod steel guys
at the very beginning those are the ones
who end up making all the money okay
meanwhile
our education system is just in tatters
okay let's just be real about this our
public education system
sucks it is not good the latest
indicator that our public education
system sucks
is on tuesday night the san francisco
school board voted to accept the
recommendations of a renaming
committee is according to emily's
inaudible they voted to officially
rename
44 public schools in san francisco
bearing the names of controversial
historical figures
these figures include abraham lincoln
george washington
theodore roosevelt franklin delano
roosevelt herbert hoover
paul revere thomas edison and senator
dianne feinstein
who was once the mayor of san francisco
san francisco commissioned the renaming
committee in october of 2019
they announced they were putting in the
committee's name change recommendations
to a vote in december and they kept
claiming oh you know it's just a
recommendation we're not going to do
anything well then they did it
then they did it so what is the big
problem with uh feinstein so according
to a 1984 copy
of workers vanguard quote unquote dixie
feinstein
raised a confederate flag at san
francisco civic center while she was
mayor of the city and later replaced the
flag after it was pulled down
by protesters but it turns out that that
was part of a historical flags display
and it wasn't clear that feinstein had
anything to do with it doesn't matter
her name comes off the high schools
abraham lincoln ran afoul of the
committee because he did not demonstrate
that black lives mattered to him
that's a hot take there san francisco
abraham lincoln
you know the man who was shot to death
in a theater after
ending the civil war and issuing the
emancipation proclamation
he didn't believe that black lives
matter solid take there san francisco
really well done really what they should
have just gone with
is that he was a homophobe and here's
the thing you could use that for like
everyone including barack obama up to
like 2011.
it's good you can just we should just
rename all of the schools every
single school in favor uh we need to
find
the locus person and that person all the
schools will be named after i'm talking
about we need like
a one-quarter black one-quarter native
american
one-quarter south american one-quarter
chinese little person transgender
pansexual that's what we need we'll find
that person and that person will name
all of the high schools after
we don't know who that is yet but could
be you it could be your lucky day if you
are that person if i just described you
please send your application in
to the san francisco school board
according to the san francisco chronicle
many san francisco parents
as well as mayor london breed argued the
effort was ill-timed given the pandemic
oh yeah it's just the bad timing that's
the problem by the way the move is going
to cost san francisco's school district
millions of bucks because they actually
have to go through
and rename all of this but what does
money matter in schooling after all i
mean one one thing that we definitely
know
is that when it comes to schooling it's
the teachers unions who rule the roost
over in chicago they've got disaster on
the mind chicago public schools has now
directed parents to keep their students
home again on thursday
because the chicago's teacher union is
moving closer to a strike by the way
that's illegal
as far as i'm aware cps said in an email
to parents on wednesday evening quote
chicago teachers union leadership
continues to direct their members who
support pre-k and cluster programs to
remain at home
therefore we must we must ask parents to
continue keeping your children home
as we are unable to guarantee adequate
staffing levels to cover in-person
learning
the district will continue with remote
learning tomorrow on january
28th so good news they're just going to
keep these teachers out forever the
teachers have decided that they don't
want to work anymore
and yes that makes you selfish it does
if you decide that you want to take
public pay
and not work and you're 20 years old and
at very little risk of covered and it
turns out that you're teaching
kindergartners who aren't transmitting
it
that makes you a bad person it does i
hate to break it to you and just because
you're a teacher if you're not teaching
you're no longer a teacher
if you're not doing the job of teaching
i cannot call you a teacher at this
point i can just call you a leech off
the public taxpayer dollar
unless you are somebody who is supremely
vulnerable to coven
again if you are a young dance teacher
who is not going in
to to dance away the hours of first
graders
because of kovid you're just lying okay
it's not about your risk
it is about the fact that you prefer to
stay home and and watch
old episodes on hgtv
that that's that's all that's going on
right now
it's absurd and it has nothing to do
with the good of students obviously it
is anti-science naturally
the biden administration is doing
nothing about it nor are they even
sounding off about it
and you're going to start to see a
parent's uprising here
if democrats don't create some gap
between them and these
god-awful teachers unions parents are
going to start saying you know what i'm
not going to vote for the party that's
in hot to these folks
here for example is a frustrated
virginia parent saying that school board
cowards were not reopening our schools
they're hiding behind children but
they're not doing this for the kids
they're doing this for themselves
you're a bunch of cowards hiding behind
our children as an excuse for keeping
schools closed
you think you're some sort of martyrs
because of the decisions you're making
when the statistics
do not lie that the vast majority of the
population is not at risk from this
virus
the garbage workers who pick up my
freaking trash
risk their lives every day more than
anyone in this school system hey
fact check true fact check true okay
meanwhile the the focus in the biden
administration
is on the most important things not
opening the schools not really even
coveted stimulus
right what they're really really focused
in laser like is climate change because
100 years from now the water level is
going to be higher
so that's that's really important
important stuff and they're willing to
sacrifice jobs in the right here and the
right now in the middle of a pandemic
with the jobs market in the toilet they
are willing to sacrifice jobs
so biden's energy secretary nominee
actually admitted this
yesterday this would be uh this would be
the honorable jennifer granholm
right and she said oh yeah you know what
we may have to by the way terrible
governor of michigan she said you know
what we may have to sacrifice
some jobs that's okay i mean that'll be
fine here she goes
i think the president's plan of building
back
better which would create more jobs
in energy clean energy
than the jobs that might be sacrificed
but i will say this
no job we don't want to see any jobs
sacrificed for those
states that have these jobs in abundance
this is something we're gonna have to
work on together
to ensure that people are remain
employed
oh okay well that you know they're going
to they'll lose their jobs but you know
some jobs may have to be sacrificed
and then later the jobs will come back
around through green jobs uh the dream
of the ages green jobs you'll remember
that van jones was barack obama's green
jobs r
here is a grand total number of the
number of green jobs the van jones
provided
big old zero zero so yeah i'm sure all
the people who are losing their jobs in
the here and now
are very comforted comforted by the fact
that the measures being taken by the
biden administration to lower
carbon emissions will result over the
course of the next century
in a minute minute degree change to the
future climate
by the way if we if we abided by like
the entire paris agreement in the here
and now
the amount of climate change that we
would avert in the united states
just by the u.s abiding by it is like
0.1 degrees celsius over the course of
the next century sounds like a fantastic
deal for people who are going to lose
their jobs
right now and become government
dependents sounds awesome you know who
is very blind about this though
is the new climate czar is the climate
czar john
kerr so
you'll remember john kerry from such
things as i ran for president in 2004
and got shellacked by george
w bush and i was a garbage secretary of
state during the obama administration
now
he is back in starring in his greatest
role elitist sneering at people
who didn't marry wealthy this is his
best role
so here is uh john kerry yesterday he
said you know
if you lose your jaw up in the gauss and
destroy
maybe you can marry a ketchup heiress
yes
here's john kerry you know you look at
the consequences of black lung for a
minor for instance and measure that
against the fastest growing job in the
united states before covet
was solar power technician the same
people can do those jobs
but the choice of doing the solar power
one now is a better choice
so what president biden wants to do is
make sure
those folks have better choices that
they have alternatives that they can be
the people who go to work
to make the solar panels they were
making them here at home
well not all of us can be windsurfing
heiress marriers john kerry
truly amazing amazing stuff okay so
let's talk a little bit about john kerry
so as i say john kerry there right there
is a dude who loves him from john kerry
that dude is wealthy
because he married rich so john kerry
married the a ketchup heiress the heinz
and
he married the heinz fortune and then he
sits around and does nothing for a
living
right he is just a quote unquote public
servant he's worth a bajillion dollars
he owns a private jet by the way he
still owns a private jet well he's
well he's telling oil and gas workers
you guys are going to be out of work
maybe you can learn to
weld solar panels because you know
oil gas solar panels the same
all the same okay that is not how
jobs work the idea that you can take a
55 year old dude
who has been working in pipeline
manufacturing and simply shift him over
to making solar panels which by the way
are still some of the most overpriced
garbage in the american energy market
and then you are going to somehow create
jobs oh well we've given them more
choice
like a choice to be unemployed and then
to have a job they don't know how to do
that's fine i mean all right this is
basically john kerry just being learned
here's herman munster explaining that
you know if they lose their jobs it's
not a big deal and by the way
if they do lose their jobs it's not
because of us it's not because we are
attempting to crack down on fracking
or gas and oil exploration no it's other
market forces we're
behind this we're not no there's never
been a person more consistently wrong
across the scope of his entire life than
john kerry
his record is unblemished unblemished at
sucking at his job
he comes back from vietnam he promptly
slanders all the troops in vietnam as
human rights violators
on the order of john droscom then
he runs for senate he ends up in the
senate he spends the next several
decades sucking at everything
then he ends up running in 2004 as the
the
anti-war candidate he's against the
surge then he becomes secretary of state
where he promptly explains that no peace
deal will get done in the middle east
unless israel is forced into concessions
to the iranians and the palestinians
that was a lie and now he's back the
beautiful thing about government is you
always fail
up you always fail up so here he was
explaining you know if people lose their
jobs that's not marvel
those sounds emerging from his face
which is really really looking like a
mudslide in the hollywood hills at this
point
i think that that unfortunately workers
have been fed a false narrative no
surprise
right for the last few years they've
been fed
the notion that somehow dealing with
climate
is coming at their expense no it's not
what's happening to them is happening
because of other market forces already
taking place
and and and what the what the what the
financiers
the big banks the asset managers private
investors venture capital are all
discovering is
there's a lot of money to be made in the
creation of these new jobs
in these sectors okay no what all those
guys are doing is that you want to talk
about corruption on wall street that's
corruption on wall street you want to
talk about why the hedge fund guys
and the venture capitalists are all
investing in green energy because they
know that you
john kerry and this this silly
administration are going to be dumping
butt loads of money into the green
energy boondoggle that is these energy
sources are not nearly as efficient as
carbon that is just the reality of the
world the vast majority of emissions are
not coming from the united states 90
of all global carbon emissions are
coming from outside the united states
the united states has been lowering its
carbon emissions year on year
mostly thanks to fracking okay but again
you want to talk about market
manipulation the government
incentivizing people to spend money on
stuff that actually is not marketable
is definitely market manipulation but
good news
this is where the laser-like focus of
the of the biden administration is going
to be
on equity meaning that we are going to
look at group outcome
and pervert the notion of individual
justice and climate change so we can use
the threat of deep impact
in or or the day after tomorrow in order
to
essentially restructure the entire world
economy really really
solid stuff my favorite is is that john
kerry is just delusional all he does at
this point is he just does pr for
foreign regimes so while he was
secretary of state he was pr agent for
iran he was going around being like
iran they're nice people yes
they told us that they would be nice now
and sure they can use that money for
terrorism but i like them i'm friends
with them
you should be too so now kerry's like
you know who's great
china china's amazing
they signed the paris accords
talk to us herman
china was not adverse to working on this
with the
obama administration china was very key
to helping to get the paris agreement to
come together because the united states
and china
came together worked together put
together an opportunity to
have a working task force and then we
announced our
reductions and that gave great momentum
to the movement of europe okay and then
triangle they're gonna they're gonna
help in 2018
china's carbon emissions were on track
to grow at the fastest rate in six years
so yeah and we should definitely trust
china china definitely is not a
competitor on the world stage
and they definitely won't take advantage
of us hampering our own economy in order
to just
blow out their carbon emissions and take
advantage of the vacuum created by our
weaker markets no way
no way they're they're good people john
kerry
john kerry also says that joe biden is
going to make climate change central to
his foreign policy planning
oh goody goody gumdrops
today in the order that he will sign
that gina is described to you
he makes climate central to foreign
policy planning
to diplomacy and to national security
preparedness
it creates new platforms to coordinate
climate action across the federal
agencies and departments sorely needed
and most importantly
it commissions uh a national
intelligence estimate
on the security implications of climate
change to give
all of us an even deeper understanding
of the challenge this is the first time
a president has ever done that it's
amazing we're going to
try and spec out security implications
of a warmer climate
it's going to be super accurate we're
great at this
you are not great at this meanwhile the
white house climate advisor
says that climate just gina mccarthy the
national climate advisor
she says that climate change is the most
significant public health
challenge of our time um
okay here she is this order takes
historic strides to address
environmental injustice it creates both
a white house
interagency task force to address
environmental justice as well as an
advisory council
it directs the department of health and
human services to create an office of
climate change and health equity
because after all climate change is the
most significant
uh public health challenge of our time
okay now i feel like i need
some dry ramen and just a picture of a
cove virus
that's what i'm going to need right now
right okay so maybe our guys can animate
this in
dry ramen covet virus behind me okay
like greatest public health challenge of
our time is it climate change meaning
the gradual warming of the climate over
the next century
most of which is already baked into the
cake or is it the virus that is going to
kill half a million americans over the
course of a year
which one hmm let's think
i i can't think of any other public
health challenges that are that are on
the order of the climate slightly
warming
year on year over the course of time i
can't think of any it's amazing
i'm so glad that we are structuring our
entire government our entire executive
branch of government
around the lie that america's
systemically racist and that we ought to
be pursuing is equal group outcome
and the equally stupid lie that climate
change is the greatest challenge facing
the united states it is not the greatest
challenge facing the united states it is
a it is a problem that can be dealt with
by adaptation over the course of time
the solutions that are currently being
proposed
by the biden administration are garbage
they do not make any sense people who
study this issue generally
believe that they don't make a lot of
sense unless you have a global carbon
tax which is not something that is ever
going to happen
you are not going to radically curb
carbon emissions globally
and the amount the idea that you can
just invest in green energy and this is
going to somehow
make the innovation better if you just
dump money into
into investments in green energy that
this is somehow going to create
massively new
and wonderful variations on energy
production i'm wondering what the
evidence is for that because we've now
dumped
billions and billions of dollars into
that i'm not seeing tremendous return
on a lot of this stuff there's a real
agenda here okay there's the agenda's
two-fold one is
there a bunch of climate change uh
true sort of religious believers who
intend on killing the fossil fuel
industry utterly
right this is like michael mann right so
michael mann is a scientist
most famous for the so-called hockey
stick graph very controversial
so michael mann he says the goal here is
we have to stop the fossil fuel industry
dead
now if biden had openly campaigned on
that we're stopping fossil fuel
like stopping it dead which is what so
much of his administration would like
would have been a problem for him in
pennsylvania but uh here is michael mann
proposing just that
of course we should all do those things
that we can do in our everyday lives to
decrease our environmental footprint
what we can't allow is for polluting
interests uh
fossil fuel companies and those
promoting their agenda to somehow
convince that
us that that alone is enough because
then that takes the pressure
off of the need for systemic change for
policies
like those that biden is out lining in
his plan
to accelerate again that transition away
from
our reliance on fossil fuels okay if you
have any magical ideas
on how we are going to transition the
entire globe away from fossil fuels by
creating
an alternative energy source that is
even remotely remotely
as efficient as this love to hear them
especially from you guys in the back who
keep saying that you don't want nuclear
energy or fracking
really interested to hear how windmills
are going to solve all of our problems i
remember windmill on my car
probably the best solution by the way he
knows that it's a lie that if you reduce
your environmental footprint you
personally introduce your environmental
print he knows that that's a lie that's
going to change the climate it ain't
you digging it well in your backyard
ain't going to do a damn thing it's not
he knows it you know it john kerry knows
it they all know it okay so there's
another agenda here too
and that is the broader left-wing agenda
which is we're going to reorganize the
entire american economy
so you may have noticed that this is
always the conclusion of every statement
climate change is a grave threat to the
united states therefore let us
reorganize the entire american economy
also racial inequity a grave threat to
america
solution let's change over the entire
american economy and remold it and
remake it
you know what i noticed i noticed that
kovit is a really bad thing what if we
just remade the entire american economy
on the back of that it seems like you
have a goal
and everything that is bad in life is
then used as a means in order for you to
gain
that goal that is what it seems like so
forgive me when i don't trust
that you are being straight with the
american people on this sort of stuff
members of the biden administration
because i don't think you are you know
i've been in rooms
with the john kerry wing of the
democratic party
and behind closed doors they acknowledge
that everything that i am saying right
now is true that the vast majority of
carbon
of climate change is baked into the cake
that it is
largely too late for large-scale
mitigation that adaptation is the proper
solution
and that if you are going to actually
take measures that are effective
they have to be directed toward
developing technologies to for example
suck climate out of the air or geo
engineering right there's there's all
sorts of stuff that you could do right
building sea walls there's stuff you
could do but they don't want to do that
what they actually want to do is remake
the entire american economy
in a more socialistic mold and this is
just the lever of power by which they
think they're going to be able to do it
so if they scare the crap out of you and
they keep citing greta thundberg saying
that the world is on fire and all of
that kind of stuff
then maybe you will allow them to
completely re-mold the american economy
in the image that they always wanted to
remold it into
yeah the answer on that one is is no the
new ruling class does not get to do that
simply because
uh they are lying to you about the
nature of the climate change threat
again not saying climate change into
problem over the course of the next
century
it is is it a problem that is going to
end all human life no is it an
existential threat to humanity
no is it something that we are going to
be able to deal with as the world
innately
grows more and more prosperous which is
what's going to happen over the course
of the next century not according to me
according to william nordhaus who just
won a nobel prize in economics for his
work on climate change
right that's what's going to happen can
we deal with it yes are we going to deal
with it with any of these ham-handed
stupid ideas for remolding individual
freedom
nope you're just going to reap the
whirlwind all righty we'll be back here
later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
molestrom michael is talking about the
media blaming trump and quote unquote
white supremacy with what is happening
with
gamestop stock right now that episode is
available right this moment
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel our associate
producers are rebecca doyle and savannah
dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
internet trolls bankrupt hedge funds for
the laws john kerry tells fossil fuel
workers to learn
solar and most republicans support trump
in 2024.
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]
you